[Music]
[Applause]
Good evening
everyone Good evening Welcome
and thank you always for your work
we know how difficult it is in these
hours on these occasions So thank you
very much Thanks also to the work of
Professor Alfieri for the work he has
done with in  this today and I
would give him the floor immediately so that he can
give us some information
on the intervention that took place. Thank you
professor. Good evening everyone. So
first of all the Holy Father is well.
I think this is the news that
you and the whole world are waiting for.
and he is awake and alert and he has
already done the first joke 10
minutes ago so this afternoon the Holy
Father at the Gemelli Polyclinic
underwent surgery
scheduled for a job on a laparocele
in prisoner in correspondence with the
scars of previous
surgeries  of the past years
he had been operated on, perhaps in Argentina
for peritonitis and for
gangrenous cholecystitis and then for cystechinococcus he
had another cut on which there
was already a cruise
taking the Porpoise which in the past months caused
Santopadre to have
painful syndromes on the oral cavity  in increasingly
frequent gradients therefore
together with the other colleagues who assist
the Holy Father and together with his
personal healthcare assistant
sharing it with him it was decided to
plan this surgery
during the surgery some
tenacious adhesions were found
the adhesions were  of the
internal scars between some
mid-small intestinal anxieties on the part of, let
's say, in the middle of the small intestine
and the parietal peritoneum which caused
the symptoms that I described to you
before,
the liberation of these adhesions was therefore carried out,
these
internal scars were freed and  woken up
as we doctors say in the whole
tenual tangle which
was completely attached to the adhesions
and which caused this difficulty in
lunch
and this was therefore
repaired of the Miller defect by means of
a plastic surgery of the abdominal parity with
the aid of a prosthetic mesh
the  surgery and
general anesthesia took place without
complications and the Holy Father reacted
well to both the surgery and
the anesthesia Holy Father is already awake he has
already joked and made fun of me Thank you Thank you
for this information I don't know  if he is
available for a few minutes if there are
any questions from fellow
journalists
defender in English who are there
all over the world
Ok
Is fine
with his Ok
disaster
op Alive Today Hospital Policlinico
Gemelli Università Cattolica
[Music]
last Days And dunning The Operation  of
Found and important
connection mething The power of
And We Free Hall of editions
to per formance
[Music]
days and we keep in mind that we
operated on the Pope, an 86-year-old gentleman
who has already undergone four
surgeries who was recently
hospitalized for a  lung infection and
therefore we will clearly take all the
precautions that has just been operated on.
Give us a few days to give you an
answer on the lightness of this
laboratory.
We have already given some information on the hearings in the
afternoon regarding the fact that until the
18th. For the moment as a precaution
I am  been canceled for the moment and
for everything that will come for the
moment everything that was after at the
moment remains standing in agreement loop
wants to know exactly the day But
look the Pope is followed by a
medical team coordinated by his health assistant
our personal tear and during these
days these months in which he was experiencing
these pains it was not with an
emergency decision otherwise we would have already
operated on him yesterday we had to do the CT scan and
they were more and more frequent so
then the Pope decides you know  which says
about everything the emperor was getting
worse and worse he decided to do the surgery
today also reusing the source
so it was decided yesterday morning
if other pathology possibilities were triggered
So let's clarify
once and for all also the permit
surgery
surgery constituted  years ago it was
for a benign pathology and I want to
underline it because even now
someone asks me questions and the
diverticular stenosis which was communicated with
all the bulletins with the press office
and a benign pathology of which the Pope has
completely recovered the pathology for
which was operated on today is a
benign pathology. Now there is the post-
operative course. But once it
comes out, it will leave no trace
and no concern for what it
was operated on two years ago. Now I think. I think.
Two years ago and today.  therefore
no other pathologies have been found he
has no other diseases the Pope
[Music]
general will be on the drip the
next day start eating something
more not even like the others Thank you
professor Cristiana uploaded
the joke because the pontiff's good mood
is always the best  signal so
that you know that you know these
things because I told you all about it to
myself I talked to him 10 minutes ago and he
told me when we do the third Here he made
fun Got it Got it
[Music]
So Holy Father never had
no problem with the general anesthesia
done either two years ago or now
clearly no one likes being
operated on and put to sleep because the moment we
are put to sleep let's say
we lose consciousness so in that
sense they don't like being put to sleep
but there was no
anesthetic problem half a year ago nor in
today's one conducted by Professor
Antonelli and his team
quickly that we gave a short while ago and what
the conscious and vigilant professor also said
Excellent I would like to add if you
will allow me the opportunity I have been working
in this for many years  structure I want to
thank all the nurses,
the instrumentalists and the colleagues and all
those who let's say they put in their hands but
let's say start the car when
we say Holy Father comes to the hospital
So this really From the kibbles to the
museum everyone absolutely to the
management that coordinates everything in the
time we have  done You have the
people who collaborated at the
time of the operation and But
clearly there are there is a whole
structure behind these people who
made themselves available in every way
so that this was a success Stefano
of the period that will transform into the hospital
how much you what will you advise
Apparently regarding your trips on the agenda
to continue doing them or to reduce them or
How to separate once you recover
from the surgery not as far as
the doctor is concerned he will be able to continue
to do what is appropriate the  the only
thing I recommended to him was not to make
efforts and burdens he looked at me as if to
say I'm the pope do you think I do
I do months so as far as
the doctor is concerned there will be no
limitations
So it seems to me that there are no other
questions I thank you once again  once again the
journalists for their work for
being here and thanks to the professor for being
available also on this occasion
to give information which is
good
we will see depending on the situation but
for the moment it seems to me that many
questions we have found answers to
will certainly be there  of
information in the next few days to
ask about the progress even
hospitalists have imagined. Very good
goodbye and thank you all. Have a good
evening